Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Calling all sellers. Salesforce is hiring account executives to join us on the cutting edge of technology. Here, innovation isn't a buzzword, it's a way of life. You'll be solving customer challenges faster with agents, winning with purpose, and showing the world what AI was meant to be. Let's create the agent-first future together.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。所有销售人员请注意。Salesforce 正在招聘客户高管，邀您共同站在科技的最前沿。在这里，创新绝非空洞的流行语，而是一种生活方式。您将利用智能代理更快地解决客户难题，以使命为导向赢得胜利，并向世界展现人工智能应有的模样。让我们共同开启智能代理优先的未来。
Head to salesforce.com slash careers to learn more. A few days after his arrival on Capri, Tiberius was enjoying his seclusion when a fisherman unexpectedly came up to him and presented him with an enormous mullet. Whereupon, alarmed that someone had been able to negotiate the most inaccessible reaches of the island by climbing a pathless cliff, he ordered that the man's face should be scrubbed with the fish. I only thank my lucky stars, cried out the fisherman as he was enduring this punishment, that I didn't bring Caesar the huge lobster that I also caught, whereupon Tiberius gave
访问 salesforce.com/careers 了解详情。提比略抵达卡布里岛几天后，正享受着隐居的清静，一名渔夫却突然走到他面前，献上一条巨大的鲻鱼。随后，提比略惊恐万分，因为竟然有人能沿着没有路径的悬崖攀爬，克服岛上最险峻的地形来到他面前，于是他下令用那条鱼狠狠擦洗这个男人的脸。渔夫在承受这种惩罚时大喊道：“我唯一庆幸的是，”福星高照，“我没把捉到的大龙虾献给凯撒。”于是提比略下令
orders that the lobster should be used to grate the man's face to shreds. So what a shameful moment in Roman history this is. It's a notorious incident in the life of the emperor Tiberius, who of course ruled from AD 14 to AD 37, and it's recorded in Suetonius' great biography of the Caesars, now translated by our very own Tom Holland. So Tom, this is a very famous story it's a story that sort of captures the capriciousness and the cruelty of the age it's I be as he sits there on his pleasure island in the bay of Naples so what's going on here so big unpack this story for us. So Capri, as you say, is in the Bay of Naples and it had been appropriated by Augustus to serve him as a kind of a retreat. And actually he kept his collection of fossils there. So he had a brilliant collection of sea monsters, which were fossils that had been brought to him. And shortly before his death in AD 14, Augustus had gone there to kind of get a bit
用那只龙虾把这个男人的脸刮得稀烂。所以，这是罗马历史上多么可耻的一个时刻啊。这是皇帝提比略生平中的一件臭名昭著的事迹，他当然是在公元14年至公元37年在位，这件事被记录在苏埃托尼乌斯伟大的《凯撒传》中，该书目前由我们敬爱的汤姆·霍兰翻译。所以，汤姆，这是一个非常著名的故事，它在某种程度上捕捉到了那个时代的心血来潮和残酷，这是提比略坐在那座位于那不勒斯湾的享乐岛上发生的事，所以这里到底发生了什么？给我们详细剖析一下这个故事吧。正如你所说，卡布里岛位于那不勒斯湾，奥古斯都曾将它据为己有，作为他的一种退隐之所。事实上，他把他的化石收藏放在那里。因此，他拥有极其精彩的海怪收藏，这些都是送给他的化石。在公元14年他去世前不久，奥古斯都曾去那里寻求一点
of rest. And then he'd gone back to the mainland and traveled down the road from Naples and that was where he died. So Tiberius had inherited Capri along with all of Augustus' other properties, all his titles and his ranks and of course his status as ruler of the Roman Empire because Tiberius had been adopted by Augustus. So Tiberius gets the whole lot. So just to remind everybody, Tiberius is the second Roman emperor. Augustus has been the first and now Tiberius has succeeded. So he spends time in Rome and then he arrives in Capri and he settles there in the year 27, doesn't he?
休息。然后他回到了大陆，沿着那不勒斯的道路前行，就在那里他去世了。因此，提比略继承了卡布里岛以及奥古斯都的所有其他财产、他所有的头衔和阶级，当然还有他作为罗马帝国统治者的地位，因为提比略被奥古斯都收养了。所以提比略全盘接手了这一切。为了提醒大家，提比略是第二位罗马皇帝。奥古斯都曾是第一位，现在提比略继位了。因此他在罗马度过了一段时间，然后抵达卡布里岛，并在公元27年定居在那里，对吧？
When he's quite old. Yeah, so he's about 70 and by Roman standards, I mean, that's very old. And Tiberius essentially is doing what great statesmen who've reached the end of their lives, you know, it's perfectly legitimate. You retire to your villa, your country villa, you escape the kind of the clamor and smoke of Rome, and you enjoy what the Roman elites would call otium cum dignitate, which is basically a kind of leisure with dignity, a dignified retirement. Sounds nice, sounds lovely. It does, but what Suetonius is doing in his biography is revealing the sordid truth that
当时他已经挺老了。是的，所以他大约70岁，以罗马标准来看，我的意思是，这非常老了。提比略基本上在做那些走到人生尽头的伟大政治家们会做的事，你知道，这完全合情合理。你退隐到你的别墅，你的乡间别墅，逃离罗马的喧嚣和烟尘，享受罗马精英们所说的“有尊严的闲暇”（otium cum dignitate），这基本上是一种有尊严的悠闲，体面的退休生活。听起来不错，听起来很美好。确实如此，但苏埃托尼乌斯在他的传记中所做的是揭露那 sordid（肮脏）的真相
lies behind these seemingly impeccable motivations. And he lists them and he says that the first reason that Tiberius retires to Capri is out of terror. So, Antonius writes, Tiberius lived in the shadow not just of the loathing and hatred that he inspired, but of his own fears and of the bitter insults to which he was subject. So, that's obviously why he is so unsettled by finding that a fisherman can climb up this sheer cliff because he's expecting that he's absolutely secure there. And that's why his reaction, Suetonius implies, is so brutal. But there is another reason as well, and we touched on this in the previous episode we did, which is that alongside the
隐藏在这些看似无可挑剔的动机背后。他列举了这些原因，并表示提比略退隐到卡布里岛的第一个原因是出于恐惧。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯写道：提比略生活在阴影之中，不仅是他所激起的厌恶和仇恨的阴影，还有他自己的恐惧以及他所遭受的痛苦侮辱。所以，这显然就是为什么他发现一个渔夫能够爬上这道陡峭的悬崖时会如此不安，因为他原本指望在那里绝对安全。苏埃托尼乌斯暗示，这就是为什么他的反应如此残酷。但还有另一个原因，我们在上一期节目中也提到过这一点，那就是除了
Roman assumption that a nobleman has his right to kind of a dignified leisure is the lurking suspicion that pretty much everyone in Rome is prey to. Someone who craves privacy for its own sake, who indulges in it too much. Bad sign. And Tiberius, I mean, he never goes back to Rome following his arrival in Capri. He makes two feints to go back to the city, but he never actually enters it. The assumption in Rome therefore is that there are no good reasons for what he's doing. He is indulging the most unspeakable depravity. So again, Suetonius on this, he became notorious for the worst,
罗马人认为贵族有权享受有尊严的闲暇这一假设之外，还潜藏着一种猜疑，而罗马的几乎每个人都难逃这种猜疑：一个单纯为了隐居而渴望隐私、过度沉溺于此的人。这绝对是个坏征兆。至于提比略，我的意思是，自从他抵达卡布里岛后，他就再也没有回过罗马。他曾两次假装要回这座城市，但实际上从未踏入其中。因此，罗马民间的假设是，他所作所为毫无正当理由。他是在放纵最不可言说的堕落。所以苏埃托尼乌斯对此再次写道：他因最恶劣、
the most shocking deviancies, such as hardly to be talked or heard about and indeed strain the bounds of credibility. And then Suetonius having said that, you know, these deviancies are too shocking to be talked about, he then talks about them in great and salacious detail. And as he does so, he insists that despite having said that, you know, these stories strain the bounds of credibility, in fact, they are true. And he is reporting on gossip that has been obsessing Rome, supposedly. Suetonius tells us that the island of Capri has been renamed in Rome Capro, which is the Latin for a male goat.
最令人震惊的变态行为而臭名昭著，这些行为甚至难以启齿或耳闻，简直挑战了人们的可信度极限。然后苏埃托尼乌斯在说过这些变态行为太过震撼而难以谈及之后，接着又以极其生动猥亵的细节大谈特谈起来。当他这样做时，他坚称尽管之前说过这些故事挑战了可信度极限，但事实上它们千真万确。而且他正在报道据称一直令罗马人着迷的流言蜚语。苏埃托尼乌斯告诉我们，卡布里岛在罗马被重新命名为卡普罗（Capro），这是拉丁语中公羊的意思。
Right. So Tiberius is this kind of hideous goatish figure. And thanks to Suetonius' reports, Tiberius' reputation has never really recovered. And to this day, he has the image, I think, in the public imagination of a kind of ghoulish, blood-stained Jeffrey Epstein, a pervert, but an embittered and paranoid and murderous pervert. And it's because of this, Suetonius reports, that when Tiberius dies, the news is greeted with public exaltation. So again, Suetonius writes, so delighted were the people at the news of his death that when they first heard it, some ran about all over the place, yelling to the Tiber with Tiberius, in other words, dump his body in the river that flows through Rome. Some prayed to Mother Earth and to the souls of the departed that the dead man be given
没错。所以提比略就是这种可怕的好色之徒形象。多亏了苏埃托尼乌斯的报道，提比略的名声再也没有真正恢复过。直到今天，他在公众想象中的形象依然是一个可怕的、血迹斑斑的杰弗里·爱泼斯坦（Jeffrey Epstein）式的怪咖，一个变态，却又是一个充满怨恨、偏执且嗜杀的变态。苏埃托尼乌斯报道说，正因如此，当提比略去世时，这个消息受到了公众的狂喜迎接。于是苏埃托尼乌斯再次写道：人们对他的死讯感到如此高兴，以至于刚听到消息时，有些人到处乱跑，大喊“把提比略扔进台伯河去”，换句话说，就是把他的尸体扔进穿城而过的台伯河。有些人向大地母亲和逝者的灵魂祈祷，愿这个死者得到
no resting place except among the damned, and others yet threatened his corpse with the hook and the Gammonian steps and the flight of steps that lead from the Forum up to the Capitol, and they pass the Great Prison, and the bodies of those who've been executed are exposed on the Gammonian steps and then dragged with a hook and dumped in the Tiber. In the event, this is not the fate that is visited on Tiberius' body. Instead, it is escorted from the Bay of Naples, much as Augustus' had been when he died, back to Rome with great honor. It's cremated in a great state funeral, but the taint of this reputation has endured for two millennia. And I would say that if you were, say, casting a vampire film about, you know, the living dead in ancient Rome, Tiberius would be the emperor best qualified to star in that.
除了诅咒之地外，再无安息之所，还有人甚至用肉钩和加莫尼亚阶梯（Gammonian steps）来威胁他的尸体，那是从广场通往卡皮托利物山的阶梯，它们经过大监狱，被处决者的尸体会被展示在加莫尼亚阶梯上，然后用肉钩拖走并扔进台伯河。事实上，这并不是降临在提比略尸体上的命运。相反，它从那不勒斯湾被护送回罗马，就像奥古斯都死后那样，受到了极大的尊崇。他在一场盛大的国葬中被火化，但这种声誉上的污点已经持续了两个千年。我想说的是，如果你要为一部关于古罗马行尸走肉的吸血鬼电影选角的话，提比略将是最适合主演的皇帝。
So there are sort of two things I would say that people who know anything about Tiberius know about Tiberius. One is he's up to terrible, terrible sexual misconduct on this island, which we'll get into. And then the other is that while that is happening, there's a kind of reign of terror in Rome by the head of the Praetorian Guard, this guy called Ser Janus, who basically has deluded Tiberius and has secretly kind of taken all his power and is killing everybody in Rome. So Tiberius is simultaneously a sort of depraved old goat, but also a stupid old fool who's got no idea kind of what's going on and in whose name all these terrible things are happening. And I guess the question is, because Tiberius, we know that Tiberius was a serious person.
所以我想说，了解提比略的人都知道关于他的两件事。第一件事是他在岛上有可怕的、糟糕的性行为不端，我们等下会讲到。第二件事是，在这一切发生的同时，罗马正经历着禁卫军统领的一场恐怖统治，这家伙叫塞扬努斯（Sejanus），他基本上蒙蔽了提比略，暗中夺取了他的全部权力，并在罗马大开杀戒。因此，提比略既是一个堕落的老色鬼，又是一个愚蠢的老糊涂，根本不知道发生了什么，而所有这些可怕的事情都是以他的名义发生的。我想问题在于，既然提比略——我们知道提比略是个严肃的人。
Will Barron Very serious. Angus That he was a very, I mean, he was, he was genuinely very serious. Yeah, wasn't he? Quite humorous. Will Barron Not humorous. Angus But he has a sort of dual reputation, doesn't he? Will Barron He does. Yes, he does. Angus Yeah. We know that he's regarded as a very proficient military commander, that he's a serious politician.
威廉·巴伦 非常严肃。 安格斯 他是一个非常，我的意思是，他确实，他真的很严肃。是的，对吧？挺幽默的？ 威廉·巴伦 一点也不幽默。 安格斯 但他有一种双重声誉，不是吗？ 威廉·巴伦 的确如此。是的，确实如此。 安格斯 是的。我们知道他被认为是一位非常出色的军事指挥官，是一位严肃的政治家。
When he succeeds Augustus as emperor, nobody thinks it's bizarre or outlandish that such a man is in command of the Roman world. So the question is, is all this stuff about attacking people with fish and doing terrible things to people in swimming pools, is all this just spin and mad propaganda? Is it fake news? Or does it get to some truth about Tiberius' character or about the nature of imperial power and power corrupting? And I guess that's the question at the heart of this episode, isn't it?
当他继承奥古斯都成为皇帝时，没有人会觉得让这样一个人统领罗马世界是诡异或离奇的。所以问题是，所有这些关于用鱼袭击人、在游泳池里对人做可怕事情的故事，难道都只是政治公关和疯狂的宣传？是假新闻吗？还是说它们触及了提比略性格的某些真实面貌，或者触及了帝国权力的本质以及权力使人腐化的规律？我想这正是本期节目核心的问题所在，不是吗？
It is, and it's a brilliant question. And I think that to answer it, it's probably best to look at Suetonius' biography of Tiberius in the whole, because even though his portrayal of the Emperor in his grim old age is by far the most memorable, I mean, there is a lot more to his biography than that. And in fact, and I think this is crucial to understanding Tiberius' character and where he is coming from, Suetonius understands that Tiberius' identity is rooted very, very deep in the past with the origins of his family, the dynasty to which he belongs and is born into. And so he begins his life of Tiberius centuries before Tiberius' birth. In fact,
确实如此，这是一个绝妙的问题。我认为要回答这个问题，最好还是通盘审视苏埃托尼乌斯所写的提比略传记，因为尽管他对这位皇帝在严酷晚年的描绘最为令人难忘，但他的传记远不止于此。事实上——我认为这对于理解提比略的性格及其根源至关重要——苏埃托尼乌斯明白，提比略的身份深深扎根于过去，根植于他的家族起源以及他所属于并出生其中的王朝。因此，他在提比略出生几个世纪前就开始了提比略的生平叙述。事实上，
in the age of Romulus, who is the founder of Rome itself. And the reason he does that is that even though by adoption, Tiberius is the son of Augustus, who in turn is the adoptive son of Julius Caesar. So the Julian family, who ultimately claimed their descent from the goddess Venus. Tiberius by birth belongs to a family who actually, they are no less patrician than the Julians. They're a lot more celebrated, a lot more distinguished than the Julians historically have been. And this is a family called the Claudians. So Suetonius gives us a kind of potted history of them. He says that the Claudians had migrated to Rome shortly after the city's founding, so in the time of Romulus, and that
从罗马城的创建者罗慕路斯的时代开始。他之所以这样做，是因为尽管从名义上讲，提比略是通过被收养成为奥古斯都的儿子，而奥古斯都反过来又是尤利乌斯·恺撒的养子。所以，朱利安家族（Julian family）最终声称他们的血统可以追溯到女神维纳斯。但提比略按出生血统属于这样一个家族：他们实际上一点也不比朱利安家族逊色，在历史上甚至比朱利安家族更富盛名、更为显赫。这个家族被称为克劳狄家族（Claudians）。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯为我们提供了一部关于他们的简史。他写道，克劳狄家族在罗马建城后不久就迁移到了罗马，也就是在罗慕路斯统治时期，并且
they established themselves there. And they become probably the most famous of all the nobiles the Romans call them. So that's the word from which we get both nobleman and nobility. And they dominate the entire history of Rome once the monarchy has been expelled and Rome becomes a republic. And Suetonius writes, the hold of the Claudians on the people's affections was formidable and self-perpetuating. And they are greatly admired for their achievements. So Suetonius lists some of them. It's a Claudian who steals the Romans to fight against Pyrrhus, the Greek king, whose common has defeated them in three battles and who in the end gives up because his victories have been too Pyrrhic.
他们在那里站稳了脚跟。他们可能成为了罗马人所称的“贵人”（nobiles）中最著名的一支。这就是我们获得“贵族”（nobleman）和“贵族阶层”（nobility）这两个词的词源。一旦君主制被废除，罗马成为共和国，他们便主导了罗马的整个历史。苏埃托尼乌斯写道：克劳狄家族对民众情感的掌控力是强大且自我强化的。他们因取得的成就而备受推崇。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯列举了其中一些事迹。正是克劳狄家族的一员激励罗马人与希腊国王皮洛士作战，皮洛士的军队在三场战役中击败了罗马人，但最终因胜之不武而放弃。
And also Claudians play a leading role in the defeat of the Carthaginians. But there is also a dark strain to the record of Claudian achievement. Some of them are viewed with great hatred. So again, fighting against the Carthaginians, there's a notorious story of one Claudian who is leading a battle fleet against the Carthaginians. He gets the soothsayer to consult the holy chickens that are on board his flagship and the soothsayer, no, I'm afraid that the chickens are saying don't attack and he just has the chickens chucked into the sea and promptly loses his entire fleet. And the women of the Claudians also are simultaneously admired and condemned. So there's one of them whose chastity is so prodigious that she's able
而且，克劳狄家族在击败迦太基人的过程中也发挥了领导作用。然而，克劳狄家族的辉煌记录中也存在着黑暗的一面。他们中的一些人备受仇恨。同样，在与迦太基人作战时，有一个臭名鼎翠的故事：一位克劳狄家族的成员率领舰队对抗迦太基人。他让占卜师查看旗舰上饲养的神圣小鸡，占卜师说：“恐怕小鸡们说不要进攻”，而他竟然直接把小鸡扔进了海里，结果立刻损失了整支舰队。克劳狄家族的女性也同样既受赞赏又遭谴责。其中有一位女性的贞洁是如此惊人，据说她仅凭一己之力，
single-handedly, it's said, to pull a ship right the way up the Tiber. And there's another one, the sister of the Claudian who had chucked the chickens in the sea, who is driving through Rome in her carriage. There are crowds everywhere. She's furious. She's stuck in a traffic jam. And she says, oh, if only my brother were around to kill off a few more of these awful crowds in some terrible defeat. And she gets accused of treason for this, the only woman in Roman history to be accused of treason up until that point. So they're very charismatic, but there are lots of people who hate them. And I think that maybe the best way to imagine their kind of status in the Roman Republic
就能把一艘船一直拉到台伯河上。还有另一位，也就是把小鸡扔进海里的那个克劳狄家族成员的姐姐，当时她正坐着马车穿过罗马城。到处都是人群。她愤怒极了。她被堵在交通大堵塞中，于是说道：“唉，要是我弟弟还在，好多杀点眼前这些讨厌的人群该多好，哪怕遭遇一场惨败也行。”她因此被控叛国罪，这是罗马历史上第一位被指控叛国罪的女性。所以他们非常有魅力，但也有很多人痛恨他们。我想，想象他们在罗马共和国中的地位，最好的方式或许就是
is to imagine that in the American Republic, suppose the Kennedys had been on the scene since the days of the founding fathers, that there'd been successions of Kennedys who'd been presidents. People hate them, people love them. It's that kind of charisma that the Claudians have. And what's even worse for Tiberius, or better, depending on your viewpoint, is that both his mother and his father descended from branches of the Claudian family, aren't they? So the Kennedys have been going for 200 years and both of your parents are from different branches of that family. So he is born two years after the Ides of March. Everything has kicked off civil war and actually his father, for all his prestige and all the sort of grandeur of his name,
想象一下在美利坚共和国里，假设肯尼迪家族从开国元勋的时代就一直活跃在政坛，有一连串的肯尼迪家族成员当选总统。人们恨他们，人们也爱他们。克劳狄家族就拥有这种魅力。对提比略来说更糟的是——或者从你的角度来看更好，他的母亲和父亲都出身于克劳狄家族的不同分支，对吧？所以就好像肯尼迪家族已经延续了200年，而你的父母双方都来自那个家族的不同分支。因此他出生在“三月十五日”之后两年。一切都爆发了内战，事实上他的父亲尽管享有盛誉，名字也十分显赫，
has backed the wrong side, hasn't he, in the civil war after Julius Caesar's assassination? Yeah, so he has to kind of leave Italy in fear of his life. And he does so with his wife Livia and his baby son Tiberius. And they go first to Sicily, where Tiberius, his father is very arrogant, as all the Claudians are supposedly arrogant. So he has a bust up there with the guy in charge of Sicily and then he goes to Greece and they're in Sparta and there's a terrible fire and they have to escape and Livia's hair gets singed. So all kinds of close shaves and it's looking very bad for him. So eventually he goes to Antony, who
却在尤利乌斯·恺撒遇刺后的内战中押错了边，不是吗？是的，所以他不得不为了保全性命而离开意大利。他带着妻子莉维亚（Livia）和婴儿时期的儿子提比略一同逃亡。他们首先去了西西里岛，在这里提比略的父亲表现得非常傲慢，正如所有克劳狄家族的人据称那样傲慢。因此他在那里与负责西西里岛的官员大吵了一架，随后他前往希腊来到斯巴达，结果遭遇了一场可怕的大火，他们不得不逃跑，莉维亚的头发都被烧焦了。经历了种种千钧一发的险境，他的处境看起来非常糟糕。最终他投奔了
is ruler of the eastern half of the empire, and makes up with him and there's an amnesty proclaimed and Tiberius' father, Livia, and the baby Tiberius are then able to go back to Rome where an incredible scandal breaks out because while Antony's in the east, Augustus, as he will come to be known, is the ruler of Rome. And so Tiberius's parents are now in the shadow of Augustus and Suetonius reports the consequence. It was with Antony that Tiberius's father returned to Rome and here, pressed by Augustus to surrender him his wife, Livia, despite the fact that Livia was pregnant at the time and had already born him a son, he did so. He died not long afterwards and was survived by two sons, Tiberius and his younger brother, Drusus. So very shocking.
统治帝国东半部的安东尼（Antony），并与他和解，随后颁布了大赦令，于是提比略的父亲、莉维亚以及婴儿提比略得以返回罗马，在那里爆发了一场难以置信的丑闻：当安东尼在东方时，后来被称为奥古斯都的人成为了罗马的统治者。因此，提比略的父母现在生活在奥古斯都的阴影之下，苏埃托尼乌斯记录了这一后果：提比略的父亲是与安东尼一同返回罗马的，在这里，在奥古斯都的逼迫下，要求他交出妻子莉维亚，尽管当时莉维亚已经怀有身孕，并且已经为他生过一个儿子，但他还是照办了。不久后他便去世了，留下了两个儿子，提比略和他的弟弟德鲁苏斯（Drusus）。所以这非常令人震惊。
Yeah. A quick question. So are we to believe that this is basically that Augustus has genuinely fallen in love with this bloke's wife? It's a genuine love match. I mean, that would, that's the only explanation, isn't it really? Right. And because crucially, Livia does not give Augustus any children and particularly any sons. And so this opens up the massive question of who is going to succeed him. It's obviously very useful for Tiberius and his younger brother, Drusus, to be the step-sons of the most powerful man in the world, the step-sons of Augustus. But equally, it does redound greatly to Augustus' prestige to have a Claudian wife and two Claudian
是的。一个简单的问题。所以我们是否应该相信，这基本上是奥古斯都真的爱上了这个家伙的妻子？这是一场真正的爱情。我的意思是，那，那是唯一的解释，不是吗？确实如此。而且至关重要的是，莉维亚没有给奥古斯都生任何孩子，尤其是没有生儿子。这就引发了一个巨大的问题：谁将继承他的大统？对于提比略和他的弟弟德鲁苏斯来说，成为世界上最有权势之人的继子、成为奥古斯都的继子，显然非常有利。但同样，拥有一位克劳狄家族的妻子和两位克劳狄家族的继子，也极大地提升了奥古斯都的声望，
step-sons because although Augustus is the grandson of Julius Caesar, his own father had not been a prestigious figure. He'd basically been a kind of out of town guy. He's representative of the Italian nobility, not of the kind of high patrician Roman nobility. So it's good for him. It kind of, you know, upgrades his status. And what is also very useful for Augustus is that Tiberius, as he grows up in Augustus's family, proves to be a man of remarkable accomplishment.
因为尽管奥古斯都是尤利乌斯·恺撒的外孙，但他自己的父亲并不是一个显赫的人物。他基本上只是一个来自外地的人。他代表的是意大利地方贵族，而不是那种高贵的罗马显赫门阀。所以这对他是件好事。这在某种程度上提升了他的地位。对奥古斯都非常有利的另一点是，随着提比略在奥古斯都的家族中长大，他被证明是一个极有才干的人。
And Suetonius gives us all the details of this. Suetonius reports that Tiberius is exceedingly clever, exceedingly well-read, very, very interested in all kinds of intellectual pursuits, and particularly in mythology, in the study of the gods, and in the literature of Greece and Rome. He's also a very effective administrator. So even as a very young man, he's charged by Augustus – again, to quote Suetonius here – making up a shortfall in the supply of grain to Rome. I mean, that's a crucial thing. If Rome is not kept supplied, then Augustus' regime will topple. So it's a real marker of trust. And then Augustus
苏埃托尼乌斯为我们提供了这一切的详细信息。苏埃托尼乌斯报道说，提比略极其聪明、博学多才，对各种知识追求都表现出极大的兴趣，特别是在神话学、神灵研究以及希腊和罗马文学方面。他还是一位非常高效的行政官员。因此，甚至在很年轻的时候，他就被奥古斯都委以重任——再次引用苏埃托尼乌斯的话——去弥补罗马粮食供应的短缺。我的意思是，这是一件至关重要的事情。如果罗马的粮食供应得不到保障，奥古斯都的政权就会垮台。所以这是信任的真正标志。然后奥古斯都
commissions the young Tiberius to launch a thorough investigation into the slave barracks across Italy, the owners of which had a terrible reputation for seizing and imprisoning not just travelers, but men whose fear of military service had driven them to hide out there. And again, that's really important because Augustus does not want his regime to be associated with conditions of internal instability. He wants order, really important for his popularity. So this is a real kind of demonstration of his trust in Tiberius. And then on top of that, Tiberius proves to be a brilliant military leader, far the best of his generation, to the extent that later
委任年轻的提比略对意大利全境的奴隶营进行彻底调查，这些奴隶营的主人臭名昭著，不仅抓捕和囚禁旅客，还囚禁那些因害怕兵役而躲藏到那里的男子。同样，这非常重要，因为奥古斯都不希望他的政权与国内政局不稳联系在一起。他渴望秩序，这对其声望至关重要。因此，这是对提比略信任的真正体现。除此之外，提比略被证明是一位杰出的军事统领，远超他那一代的所有人，以至于后来
in his life, whenever there is a major crisis on the frontiers, it is Tiberius to whom Augustus turns. And it's not going too far to say that Tiberius is twice the savior of his country. So the first of these great feats of repairing Rome and ensuring that her frontiers are not overwhelmed takes place in 86 when there's a great revolt in Pannonia. So basically what's now Hungary, he crushes that. And the second is in the aftermath of the great disaster of Augustus' reign, which is the defeat of the three legions under the command of Barros by the Germans in 89 and is Tiberius who ensures that that disaster does not lead to the complete collapse of the frontier and Germans flooding into Gaul and Italy.
在他的生命中，每当边境出现重大危机时，奥古斯都求助的对象总是提比略。说提比略是国家的两度拯救者并不过分。因此，这两次修复罗马并确保其边境免受蹂躏的伟大壮举中的第一次，发生在他于公元6年平息潘尼亚（Pannonia）大起义之时。基本上就是现在的匈牙利，他粉碎了那场起义。第二次则发生在奥古斯都统治时期最大灾难的余波之中，即瓦鲁斯（Varus）率领的三个军团在公元9年被日耳曼人击溃，正是提比略确保了这场灾难没有导致边境彻底崩溃以及日耳曼人大举涌入高卢和意大利。
So Suetonius quotes a letter that Augustus wrote to Tiberius during these kind of later years in which he writes to Tiberius addresses him as dearest and bravest and most dutiful of generals. So you know this is a very very impressive man. So if you were pointing purely on merit, Tiberius is obviously obviously the best qualified, the outstanding candidate to succeed Augustus when the time comes as emperor, as master of the Roman world. But we know from Suetonius' account that Augustus basically tries to do everything possible, not everything possible to avoid it, but he's constantly looking at other candidates from his own family. So Tiberius is his stepson, not his son.
因此，苏埃托尼乌斯引用了一封奥古斯都在这些晚年写给提比略的信，信中奥古斯都称提比略为“最亲爱、最勇敢、最尽责的将领”。所以你知道，这是一个非常非常了不起的人。因此，如果你完全根据才能来评判，提比略显然、绝对是合格的最佳人选，是当时机成熟时继承奥古斯都成为皇帝、成为罗马世界主宰的出色候选人。但我们从苏埃托尼乌斯的记述中知道，奥古斯都基本上试图做一切可能的事——倒也不是不惜一切代价避免它——但他一直在物色自己家族中的其他候选人。所以提比略是他的继子，而不是亲生儿子。
And what Augustus really wants is his own flesh and blood. So his grandsons to succeed him. Because he's had a daughter, hasn't he Augustus? Yeah. Called Julia, who is not his daughter by Livia, but by a previous wife. Exactly. And he wants her children to succeed him, not this guy who's somebody else's son. Right. Because that's what every Roman nobleman wants. You know, they want their bloodline to be perpetuated. So, Julia has given him various kind of grandsons and granddaughters, and Augustus has adopted the eldest of his three grandsons, guys called Gaius and Lucius, directly as his sons. So this is marking them
奥古斯都真正想要的是自己的骨肉。也就是他的孙子们来继承他。因为他曾有过一个女儿，奥古斯都，对吧？是的。名叫尤利娅，不是他和莉维亚所生，而是和前妻所生。没错。他希望她的孩子继承他，而不是这个别人的儿子。没错。因为这正是每个罗马贵族所追求的。你知道，他们希望自己的血统能够延续下去。因此，尤利娅为他生了几个外孙和外孙女，奥古斯都直接收养了他三个外孙中的年长者，分别叫盖乌斯（Gaius）和卢修斯（Lucius），作为自己的儿子。所以这标志着
out as the heirs. And Tiberius is very, very sensitive to the fact that he's not in the line of succession and he makes a real point of trying not to tread on the toes of Gaius and Lucius, who of course are much younger than him, much less experienced, much less able. And he, you know, he does his best, but he is a Claudian. I mean, he's a very proud man and he can't really help but betray his resentment. So this happens in various ways. So Augustus marries Julia, his daughter, to Tiberius and Tiberius and Julia don't get on at all. At one point, Tiberius is so aggravated by the situation he finds himself that he chucks
他们被指定为继承人。提比略对于自己不在继承序列中感到非常非常敏感，他刻意避免踩到盖乌斯和卢修斯的脚趾头，当然他们比他年轻得多、经验少得多、能力也差得多。他呢，你知道，他尽了最大努力，但他毕竟是个克劳狄家族的人。我的意思是，他是一个极度骄傲的人，无法真正掩饰自己的怨恨。因此，这以各种方式表现出来。奥古斯都将他的女儿尤利娅嫁给提比略，而提比略和尤利娅根本合不来。有一次，提比略对自己的处境感到如此恼火，以至于他
everything in and he retires to Rhodes and he does it in a way that seems very openly to insult Augustus who has publicly requested him not to go and relations between the two men break down so badly that in the event when Tiberius says, well I quite like, I've had enough of Rhodes, I want to come back now, Augustus forbids it. So effectively Tiberius is in exile and actually in a measure of danger from Lucius and Gaius, who, you know, obviously in turn feel menaced by this very able, they're kind of elder. But then in, first of all, in 82 Lucius dies and then in 84 Gaius dies. And this is basically the kind of the plot twist in I Claudius that
抛下一切退隐到了罗得岛（Rhodes），他的做法似乎公然侮辱了奥古斯都，因为奥古斯都曾公开请求他不要离开，两人之间的关系彻底破裂，以至于后来当提比略说：“我挺喜欢……我在罗得岛待够了，现在我想回来了”，奥古斯都却严词拒绝。因此提比略实际上处于流放状态，而且实际上也面临着来自卢修斯和盖乌斯的某种危险，他们（显然反过来也感到被这个非常有能力的年长者所威胁）。但随后，首先在公元2年卢修斯去世，接着在公元4年盖乌斯去世。这基本上就是《我，克劳狄》（I Claudius）中的情节反转：
it's Livia, Tiberius' mother, who is poisoning them and kind of elbowing aside anyone who might stand in the path of her son to succeed to the throne. But in reality, they don't have natural causes. They're not poisoned, are they? No, I mean, almost certainly not. And their death means that effectively Augustus now has no choice but to adopt Tiberius as his heir. And this means
是莉维亚——提比略的母亲——在毒死他们，并排挤任何可能阻挡她儿子继承王位的人。但在现实中，他们并不是死于非命，不是被毒死的，对吧？不，我的意思是，几乎可以肯定没有。他们的死意味着，实际上奥古斯都现在别无选择，只能收养提比略为他的继承人。这意味着
that Tiberius ceases to be a Claudian and he now becomes a Julian. This is what qualifies him to rank as a Caesar. And it's a public proclamation to the world that Tiberius is now Augustus' heir. And sure enough, on the 17th of September, AD 14, when Augustus dies, he is succeeded to the rule of the Roman world by his adoptive son, Tiberius Julius Caesar Augustus. And people will note that in that name, there is no hint of his Claudian ancestry. Okay. So he's had the most fantastic apprenticeship to become emperor. And then we get into the
提比略不再是克劳狄家族的人，他现在成为了朱利安家族的人。这正是他获得“恺撒”头衔资格的原因。这也是向全世界公开宣告提比略现在是奥古斯都的继承人。果不其然，在公元14年9月17日奥古斯都去世时，他由他的养子提比略·尤利乌斯·恺撒·奥古斯都（Tiberius Julius Caesar Augustus）继位统治罗马世界。人们会注意到，在这个名字中，没有一丝一毫他克劳狄家族血统的痕迹。好了。所以他经历了成为皇帝最不可思议的学徒生涯。然后我们进入了
stories in Suetonius' account. We get into the story of how Tiberius actually does, and actually it's not all attacking people with fish. Perving on islands and stuff. A lot of it is he's actually really good at being emperor, and he's a very proficient and serious and impressive one. So there are whole chunks of Suetonius' account of Tiberius as an emperor that makes him sound an absolutely mortal ruler. So, Suetonius says of Tiberius that although he's emperor, he conducted himself much as any citizen in the days of the Republic might have done,
苏埃托尼乌斯记述中的种种故事。我们了解到了提比略实际上的所作所为——其实并不全是用鱼攻击别人、
and indeed for a while with fewer heirs. So, in other words, Tiberius is reassuring his fellow citizens that just because he has inherited Augustus' powers, that doesn't mean that the civic ideals of the Republic are being kind of thrown in the dust. He's not a monarch. He doesn't conduct himself like a monarch. He does not. Well, this is what Suetonius tells us. And also he therefore is very quick to scorn flattery. So he gets addressed by someone as Dominus, master, and Tiberius is appalled. And Suetonius says he told the man never to call him by such an insulting title again. And Suetonius specifies that Tiberius shows immense respect towards the Senate, who were the great body of leading men,
在岛上猥亵他人之类的事。其中很大一部分是，他实际上非常擅长做皇帝，而且是一位非常精干、严肃和令人印象深刻的皇帝。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯关于提比略作为皇帝的记述中有整整大段内容，把他描绘成一个完全无可挑剔的统治者。因此，苏埃托尼乌斯说，尽管提比略贵为皇帝，但他的行为举止与共和国时代的任何普通公民无异，
who had guided Rome throughout the centuries of the Republic. He honours the ancient traditions of free speech. People are allowed to insult him if they want to. As he had done as a young man, so as emperor, he secures the public peace against banditry, brigandage, and sedition. And he shows concern for the security, stability, and wellbeing of the provinces. And to governors who urged him to impose a heavier tribute on the provinces, Serotonius writes, he wrote back that a good shepherd should shear his flock not skin them. Tiberius is a man who is concerned not just with the peace of the provinces, but with ensuring that they're prosperous. So this all seems to be great.
甚至在一段时间里表现得更加谦逊。换句话说，提比略是在向他的同胞们保证，仅仅因为他继承了奥古斯都的权力，并不意味着共和国的公民理想就被抛诸脑后。他不是君主。他的行为举止不像君主。他确实不是。好吧，这就是苏埃托尼乌斯告诉我们的。因此，他也很不屑于阿谀奉承。所以当有人称呼他为主人（Dominus）时，提比略大惊失色。苏埃托尼乌斯说，他告诫那个人永远不要再用这种侮辱性的头衔称呼他。苏埃托尼乌斯具体指出，提比略对元老院表现出极大的敬意，元老院是那些杰出领袖的庞大集体，
It all sounds brilliant. But then you read this and then comes a kind of key pivot point in the biography. And Suetonius writes, only gradually did Tiberius reveal the true character of his rule. And Suetonius' thesis is that the older Tiberius becomes, so the harder he finds it to restrain the monstrous vices that had always secretly been gnawing at him. And there are two vices in particular, one of which we've already discussed, it's his sexual perversities, his pawling deviancies, but also the fact that Tiberius secretly is a monster of cruelty. Right, and that takes us back obviously to that introduction, the business with the fishermen, which we will come to. Take the cruelty first. I recently reminded myself reading your excellent
正是他们在共和国的几个世纪里指引着罗马。他尊重言论自由的古老传统。如果人们想侮辱他，那是被允许的。正如他年轻时那样，作为皇帝，他保障了公共和平，打击了土匪、强盗和叛乱。他关心各行省的安全、稳定和福祉。对于敦促他向各行省征收更重赋税的总督们，苏埃托尼乌斯写道，他回信说：“好牧人应该剪羊毛，而不是剥羊毛。”提比略不仅关心各行省的和平，还确保它们繁荣昌盛。所以这一切看起来都棒极了。
translation of Suetonius, that he particularly targets his rivals, so the other descendants of Augustus, the rest of the family, people who might be a plausible threat to him. And he does that actually quite late, doesn't he? So he's been emperor for 15 years. He's actually been off on his pleasure island on Capri for two years. And now he decides, okay, I'm going to get rid of all Augustus's other descendants. That seems a bit weird to me. Right.
听起来太棒了。但随后你读到这里，传记中便出现了一个关键的转折点。苏埃托尼乌斯写道：提比略只是逐渐地显露了他统治的真实面目。苏埃托尼乌斯的论点是：提比略年龄越大，他就越觉得难以克制那些长期以来暗中啃噬他的可怕恶习。其中有两项恶习尤为突出，其中一项我们已经讨论过了，那就是他的性变态、他那见不得人的畸形癖好，此外还有一个事实，即提比略暗地里是个残酷的怪物。没错，这显然把我们带回了开头的那个故事——那个关于渔夫的故事，我们一会儿会讲到。先说说残酷吧。我最近在重读你那部极佳的
So, yeah. seems a bit weird to me. Right, so yeah, so in AD 29 he exiles the woman who is Augustus's last surviving grandchild. And this is a woman called Agrippina. She's much loved and admired by the Roman people, great favourite, but Tiberius doesn't care. He has her exiled to a remote and distant island. And she has given birth to three sons. The oldest of these is called Nero, the middle one is called Drusus, the youngest is called Gaius and he goes by an affectionate nickname Caligula. Little boots or whatever. Yes, so he's the youngest. So the two elders, Nero and Drusus, Tiberius had adopted them and that of course is to signal to the world,
苏埃托尼乌斯译作时提醒自己，他特别针对自己的政敌，也就是奥古斯都的其他后代、家族中的其他人、那些可能对构成他构成潜在威胁的人。而且他实际上下手很晚，不是吗？所以他当皇帝已经15年了。他实际上已经在他的享乐岛卡布里岛上待了两年。现在他决定，好吧，我要除掉奥古斯都的所有其他后代。这在我看来有点奇怪。没错。
to the Roman people, that these rank as his heirs. He wants them to succeed him. But when their mother falls from favor, so do they. So Nero, like Agrippina, is exiled to a remote island and Drusus is kind of chained up in the bowels of the great palace on the Palatine Hill in Rome. And within four years, all three of them are dead. And Suetonius does not spare the reader the hideous details. Agrippina, we're told that she is beaten so badly in prison on her island that she loses an eye. She goes on hunger strike. On Tiberius' orders, she's forcibly fed, but she just keeps spitting food up and ultimately she dies of starvation. Suetonius writes that Nero was driven to commit suicide after an executioner, pretending that he had been sent by order
所以，是的，在公元29年，他流放了奥古斯都在世的最后一个孙辈。这是一个叫阿格里皮娜（Agrippina）的女性。她深受罗马人民的喜爱和推崇，是个大红人，但提比略根本不在乎。他把她流放到了一个偏远而遥远的岛上。她生了三个儿子。其中最大 A 的叫尼禄（Nero），居中的叫德鲁苏斯，最小的叫盖乌斯，他有一个昵称叫卡利古拉（Caligula）。
of the Senate showed him a garrote and hooks and that Drusus was reduced to such torments of hunger that he tried to eat the stuffing of his mattress. So these are the stories that are told. Ricky, the only one left is this youngest one, Gaius Caligula. Yeah. And of course we will be coming to him next week. So I'm not content with that. According to Suetonius, Tiberius then becomes even more savage and brutal,
小靴子之类。是的，所以他是老幺。因此，对于两个年长的哥哥尼禄和德鲁苏斯，提比略曾收养他们，这当然是在向全世界、向罗马人民发出信号，表明他们位列他的继承人。他希望他们继承自己。但当他们的母亲失宠时，他们也随之失宠了。所以尼禄像阿格里皮娜一样被流放到了一个偏远的岛上，而德鲁苏斯则被铁链锁在罗马帕拉蒂尼山上宏伟宫殿的深处。在四年内，他们三人全部丧命。苏埃托尼乌斯没有对读者隐瞒那些可怕的细节。我们得知，阿格里皮娜在岛上的监狱里遭到如此惨烈的殴打，以至于瞎了一只眼。她开始绝食。在提比略的命令下，人们强行给她喂食，但她一直把食物吐出来，最终因饥饿而死。苏埃托尼乌斯写道，尼禄是在一个行刑者假装奉元老院的命令向他展示绞索和肉钩后被迫自杀的，而德鲁苏斯则被折磨到极度饥饿，以至于试图吃掉床垫里的填料。这些就是流传下来的故事。
doesn't he? Because there's been a failed coup against him, hasn't there? His former right-hand man, a guy called Ser Janus, who has supposedly been carrying out this reign of terror in Rome, turns against Tiberius, he's accused of leading the coup. Tiberius gets rid of him and then Tiberius just goes mad and starts killing everybody. Is that basically the gist of it? That is the gist of it. I mean, it's very mafia. Ser Janus is kind of Tiberius's concilierie.
里奇，唯一剩下的就是这个老幺盖乌斯·卡利古拉了。是的，当然我们下周就会讲到他。不仅如此，根据苏埃托尼乌斯的说法，提比略随后变得更加残暴和野蛮，
He's trying to take out the boss, it's failed. And so, you know, the aging godfather launches these terrible reprisals. And again, Suetonius, who loves a shocking atrocity, he doesn't spare us the details. So he says of the people who've been fingered in this conspiracy, all those put to death were flung down the Gammonian steps, dragged away on hooks. Since it was strictly forbidden by tradition to strangle virgins, the executioner made sure to rape young girls before throttling them, which I always think is a complete, you know, such a repellent detail. And then anyone who wished to die was forced to live again, a kind of, you know, cruel refinement. The poor fisherman who brought
不是吗？因为曾经有过针对他的未遂政变，对吧？他以前的得力助手、据称一直在罗马实施恐怖统治的家伙——塞扬努斯，背叛了提比略，他被指控领导政变。提比略除掉了他，然后提比略就彻底疯狂了，开始大开杀戒。基本上就是这么回事吗？ 这基本上就是怎么回事。我的意思是，这非常像黑手党。塞扬努斯有点像提比略的军师，
Tiberius the mullet with which we began this episode, he's not the only guy who gets flung from a cliff. So, on Caprisius, who Atonius writes, the place where Tiberius used to watch executions is still pointed out. So there's a bit of field research. The very spot from where those found guilty after protracted and excruciating tortures would be flung on his command into the sea, down to where a band of marines would be waiting to smash the corpses with poles and oars, just on the off chance that any might still have the breath of life. And then Suetonius gives us a particularly hideous torture that Tiberius has devised himself. No sooner had his victims been tricked into filling themselves to bursting with a large
他试图干掉老大，结果失败了。所以，你知道，年迈的教父发动了这些可怕的报复。同样，苏埃托尼乌斯热爱令人震惊的暴行，他也没有对我们手软。所以他谈到那些卷入这场阴谋的人时说：所有被处决的人都被扔下加莫尼亚阶梯，用肉钩拖走。由于传统严禁勒死处女，行刑者在勒死年轻女孩之前确保先强奸她们，我一直觉得这是一个极其令人作呕的细节。接着，任何想死的人都被强迫活过来，这是一种残酷的折磨。那个给提比略带去了我们本期节目开头的鲻鱼的倒霉渔夫，并不是唯一一个被从悬崖上扔下去的人。因此，在卡布里岛，苏埃托尼乌斯写道：提比略用来观看行刑的地方至今仍被指明。所以还有一些实地考察。正是在那个地方，那些经受长期残酷折磨而被判有罪的人，会在他的命令下被抛入大海，下方会有一队海军陆战队员拿着长篙和船桨准备把尸体砸碎，以防其中有人还有一丝生息。随后，苏埃托尼乌斯向我们描述了一种提比略亲自设计、极其可怕的刑罚。受害者刚被哄骗着喝下大量美酒，撑得肚皮滚圆，他们的尿道就会被紧紧绑住，这样一来，他们既要忍受绳索勒紧的剧痛，又要忍受膀胱胀裂的痛苦。我其实很难想象这在物理上是如何运作的，但可以说，要么是提比略，要么是苏埃托尼乌斯，拥有极其奇特的想象力。你觉得这样说公道吗，汤姆？我认为完全公道。萨德侯爵（Marquis de Sade）在他的图书馆里藏有一本苏埃托尼乌斯的作品，也就不足为奇了。因为当然，除了残暴之外，还有他据称沉溺其中的性犯罪。苏埃托尼乌斯描述这些罪行的段落，
quantity of wine than their urethras would be bound tight so that they would be put into agony both by the tightening of the cord and by the distending of their bladders. I'm actually struggling to work out how physically that would work, but it's fair to say that either Tiberius or Suetonius has a very strange imagination. Do you think that's fair, Tom? I think it's entirely fair. And it's not surprising that the Marquis de Sade kept a copy of Suetonius in his library. Because of course, as well as the cruelty, there are these sex crimes that he's supposedly indulging in. And the passages where Suetonius describes them,
我认为绝对是《凯撒传》中最令人作呕的部分，在整个罗马文学中也很有可能是最恶劣的，这真是不简单。苏埃托尼乌斯自己也说，这些变态行为不应该被讨论，但接着他当然还是讨论了。我想最臭名昭著的例子，可能也是熟悉这个故事的人都听说过的例子，就是苏埃托尼乌斯声称提比略训练了一些被他称为“小鲻鱼”的小男孩，让他们在他游泳时从他的大腿之间滑过，用舌头的搅动和顽皮来戏弄他。
I think, definitely the most revolting section in the lives of the Caesars, quite possibly in the whole of Roman literature, which is saying something. And Suetonius himself, he says that these deviants, that they shouldn't be discussed, and then of course he does. And I suppose the most notorious example, probably the one that people who are familiar with this story will have heard of is Suetonius claims that Tiberius trained little boys whom he called his minnows to slip between his thighs as he was swimming and to tease him with the swirling of their tongues and the playfulness
我认为，这绝对是《恺撒传》中最令人作呕的部分，很可能也是整个罗马文学中最令人作呕的部分，这话可不轻。苏埃托尼乌斯自己也说，这些变态行径不应该拿出来讨论，但紧接着他当然还是讨论了。我想最臭名昭著的例子——可能熟悉这个故事的人都听说过——就是苏埃托尼乌斯声称，提比略训练了一些被称为“小鱼”的小男孩，在他在水中游泳时，从他的大腿间滑过，用舌头的翻搅和嬉戏来逗弄他
of their nibbling. And that is by no means the worst. No, it gets worse, doesn't it? It does get worse. And all these sections where Pseudotonius is describing not just what is being done to Tiberius himself, but he's kind of staging erotic pageants, floor shows. It's quite hard to work out exactly what is going on, what positions are being adopted, because it's almost as though the Latin itself is breaking down as though Pseudotonius is struggling to articulate the complexity of all these kind of weird sex acts that Tiberius is commissioning. And,
它们在啃咬。这绝对不是最糟糕的。不，情况更糟了，不是吗？确实更糟了。所有这些小节中，伪苏维托尼乌斯不仅在描述对提比略本人所做的事情，而且他还在某种程度上策划色情的盛大表演、现场秀。这很难确切弄清楚到底发生了什么，采取了什么姿势，因为几乎就像拉丁语本身在瓦解，就好像伪苏维托尼乌斯在艰难地表达提比略所委托的所有这些奇特性行为的复杂性，而且，
you know, as we said, this account of what Tiberius is getting up to on Capri is so shocking, so celebrated, so notorious that it has damaged Tiberius's reputation for two millennia. But to return to the question that you asked, beginning of this half, you know, is it biographical fact or is it muck raking? I think it is really telling that actually all the stuff that we've also been talking about in this episode, all the stuff about him investigating slave barracks and, you know, leading armies, sorting out the grain supply. I mean, nobody remembers that. That's all kind of boring. It's the lurid quality of what's being described. And I think that these seem to exist in a completely different dimension. So it's as though in the biography we have Tiberius is a Roman politician like
你知道的，正如我们所说，这段关于提比略在卡普里岛上所作所为的描述是如此令人震惊、如此著名、如此臭名昭著，以至于它已经损害了提比略两千年的声誉。但回到你在这半场开始时提出的问题，你知道，这是传记事实还是泼脏水？我认为这非常说明问题，实际上我们这一集里一直在谈论的所有事情，所有关于他调查奴隶 barracks（兵营）、你知道的，率领军队、整理粮食供应的事情。我的意思是，没有人记得这些。那些都有点无聊。这是所描述事情的耸人听闻的性质。而且我认为这些似乎存在于一个完全不同的维度。所以就好像在传记中我们有提比略作为一个罗马政治家，就像
any other, the kind of figure who might appear in, you know, Livy or something like that. And then on Capri, he seems like some monster from some hideous tragedy or monstrous epic poem. And I think that the clue to what is going on with Suetonius and indeed with Tiberius lies in that. it's the fact that Tiberius is being portrayed both as an emperor like any other, but also as a figure of myth. That's the key to understanding him. All right. Well, let's explore this a little bit more after the break. Like so worried about my sister.
任何其他人一样，那种可能出现在，你知道的，李维或其他类似著作中的人物。然后在卡普里岛上，他看起来就像某些可怕悲剧或怪物史诗中的某个怪物。我认为苏维托尼乌斯以及提比略身上所发生事情的线索就在于此。这就是事实：提比略既被描绘成一个像其他任何人一样的皇帝，也被描绘成一个神话人物。这就是理解他的关键。好吧，那我们在休息之后再多探讨一下这个。这么担心我妹妹。
We're engaged. You cannot marry a murderer. I was sick, but I am here. Returning to W network and StacTV. The West Side Ripper is back. If you're not killing these people, then who is? That's what I want to know. Starring Kaylee Cuoco and Chris Messina.
我们订婚了。你不能和一个杀人犯结婚。我病了，但我在这里。重返W网和StacTV。西区开膛手又回来了。如果你没有杀这些人，那是谁？这就是我想知道的。由凯莉·库柯和克里斯·梅西纳主演。
The only investigating I'm doing these days is who shit their pants. Killer messaged you yesterday? This is so dangerous. I gotta get out of this. Based on a true story. New season Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on a true story. New season. Mondays at 9 Eastern and Pacific. Only on W. Stream on Stack TV. Tiberius held the rule of Earth and Sea for 23 years without once permitting so much as the merest spark of war to smolder in the lands of either the Greeks or the barbarians, and he bestowed upon the world both peace and the blessings of peace right the way
我这些天唯一在调查的是谁拉裤子里了。凶手昨天给你发信息了？这太危险了。我得离开这儿。根据真实事件改编。新季度每周一东部时间及太平洋时间9点播出。仅在W频道。在True Story上观看流媒体。新季度。每周一东部时间和太平洋时间9点播出。仅在W频道。在Stack TV上观看流媒体。提比略统治了地球和海洋23年，没有一次允许哪怕是微乎其微的战争火星在希腊人或野蛮人的土地上燃起，他向世界恩赐了和平以及和平的福祉，一直持续到
up to his dying day, and he did so what is more, with an ungrudging generosity of spirit. He was a man of deep common sense, the most skilled in penetrating to the heart of a person's secret intentions of all his contemporaries whom he surpassed in wisdom as in rank. No one on both sides of his family had a nobler ancestry. No one was more sagacious or better read. So that's not Suetonius, that's Philo of Alexandria who was a Judean philosopher and that's an obvious corrective to all the stuff about minnows and assaulting people with lobsters and killing all these people and whatnot.
他生命的最后一天，而且更重要的是，他以一种慷慨无私的精神做到了这一点。他是一个具有深厚常识的人，在他所有同时代人中，他是最擅长洞察一个人内心秘密意图的人，他在智慧和地位上都超越了他们。他的家族双方都没有更高贵的血统。没有人比他更精明或博学。所以那不是苏维托尼乌斯，那是亚历山大的斐洛，他是一位犹太哲学家，那是对所有关于米诺鱼、用龙虾袭击人以及杀死所有人诸如此类事情的一个明显的纠正。
Now, Philo obviously is not as close to the circles of Paris, Suetonius would later be. So Philo is from Alexandria, but he'd been to Rome, hadn't he? He'd been there a year after Tiberius' death. So he might well have spoken to people who knew Tiberius and, you know, he's not completely to be discounted. So Tom, what's going on here? Why does that account differ so much from the lurid kind of, I mean, I was going to
现在，斐洛显然没有苏维托尼乌斯后来那样接近巴黎的圈子。所以斐洛来自亚历山大，但他去过罗马，不是吗？他在提比略死后一年去过那里。所以他很可能和认识提比略的人交谈过，而且，你知道的，他并不是完全可以被忽略的。所以汤姆，这里发生了什么？为什么那个记述与那种耸人听闻的，我的意思是，我本来要
say Hello Magazine, but of course it's not Hello Magazine. It's far, far more scandalous than anything in Hello Magazine than that version of Tiberius. Yeah. So, I mean, maybe one answer to that puzzle, you might think, well, Philo is Greek. As you said, he's not familiar with Rome because he's from Alexandria. Perhaps he, you know, he just doesn't really have a handle on what's going on. Perhaps you have to be in Rome to get the full sense of the horrors that are being reported of Tiberius. And backup for that is the fact that we do have another very detailed source for Tiberius' reign, and that is not a biography, but a history, and it's a history written by Rome's greatest historian Tacitus, who hates Tiberius and corroborates many of Suetonius' darkest accusations. Antacetus, like Suetonius, agrees
说《Hello!》杂志，但当然它不是《Hello!》杂志。它比《Hello!》杂志中的任何内容都要 scandalous（丑闻百出）得多，比那个版本的提比略要 scandalous 得多。对的，所以，我的意思是，也许对那个谜题的一个回答，你可能会想，斐洛是希腊人。正如你所说，他不熟悉罗马，因为他来自亚历山大。也许他，你知道的，他真的对正在发生的事情没有一个掌控。也许你必须在罗马才能充分感受到关于提比略的那些被报道的可怕事情。支持这一点的证据是，我们确实拥有另一个关于提比略统治时期的非常详细的来源，那不是传记，而是一部历史，它是由罗马最伟大的历史学家塔西陀撰写的历史，他讨厌提比略，并证实了苏维托尼乌斯最黑暗的许多指控。而塔西陀像苏维托尼乌斯一样同意，
that Tiberius was hated by the Roman people when he died. And according to both men, so both the great biographer and the great historian, the Senate hated Tiberius because he had been tyrannical, vengeful, murderous, and the people had hated him because they had sensed that he despised them. He took no pleasure in the things that gave him delight. He refused to lay on public entertainments. Gladiators in his reign were complaining that they had nothing to do. And so, you know, not only is he a kind of bloodstained pervert who goes around killing
提比略死时遭到罗马人民的憎恨。根据两个人的说法——也就是伟大的传记作家和伟大的历史学家——元老院讨厌提比略，因为他残暴、好复仇、嗜杀成性，而民众讨厌他，是因为他们感觉到他鄙视他们。他从那些带给他快乐的事情中得不到乐趣。他拒绝提供公共娱乐活动。在他统治期间的角斗士们抱怨他们无所事事。所以，你知道的，不仅他是一个到处杀害元老院成员的血腥变态，
senators, he's also a massive killjoy. This is not a good image. But the fact is that actually we do know, even though it hasn't survived, that there was at least one account of Tiberius' life that was very, very laudatory. And the reason we know that is that Suetonius is clearly drawing on it. Because although he doesn't name his sources, it's evident when you read his life that what he's done is basically lifted stuff from one source, which is very positive, and he's listed other stuff from a second source, which is vituperative. And he's basically
他也是一个巨大的扫兴鬼。这不是一个好形象。但事实是，实际上我们确实知道，尽管它没有保存下来，但至少有一份关于提比略一生的记述是非常非常赞美的。我们之所以知道这一点，是因为苏维托尼乌斯显然在借鉴它。因为虽然他没有说出他的消息来源，但当你阅读他的生平记述时，显而易见的是，他所做的事情基本上是从一个非常积极的来源中提取了材料，他又从第二个来源中提取了其他材料，那个来源是恶毒漫骂的。而他基本上
just stitched them together. And he hasn't tried really to reconcile them. Well in your introduction to the 12th Caesars, which I was talking about in the last episode we did about how interesting it is, you make the point that the biography of Tiberius is the most unstable and the most unsatisfying in some ways of all the biographies in Suetonius' book because he never strikes a balance between, I mean, he just, you know, first we have all the stuff that says Tiberius is brilliant, he's doing those stuff with grain. And then we have all the stuff that says he's absolutely terrible, he's throwing people off cliffs.
只是把它们缝合在了一起。而且他并没有真正试图去调和它们。好吧，在你对《十二凯萨传》的介绍中，我在上一集里谈到过这是多么有趣，你提出了这样一个观点：提比略的传记在苏维托尼乌斯的书中的所有传记中，在某种程度上是最不稳定、最不令人满意的，因为他从未在……我的意思是，他只是，你知道的，首先我们有所有说提比略很棒的材料，他在做那些处理粮食的事情。然后我们有所有说他绝对糟糕、他把人从悬崖上扔下去的材料。
But there's no attempt by Suetonius really to make any psychological sense of the fact that you've got these two different versions of the same man's character. Right, exactly. And so that's why it's so hard to get a handle on who the real Tiberius might have been. And is it possible to get any sense of the real man, the real politician, the real emperor behind the myth? And I think it's difficult, but I think it is possible to make a case for Tiberius as having been an emperor who probably was more sinned against than sinning when it comes to Suetonius and Tacitus. And I think it's worth remembering
但苏维托尼乌斯并没有真正尝试对这样一个事实做出任何心理上的解释：你有同一个男人的性格的这两种不同的版本。对，完全是这样。所以这就是为什么很难把握真正的提比略可能是一个什么样的人。是否有可能了解神话背后的这个真实的男人、真实的政治家、真正的皇帝？我认为这很困难，但我认为有可能为提比略辩护，就苏维托尼乌斯和塔西陀而言，他可能是一个受到的伤害多于他去伤害别人的人。而且我认为值得记住的是，
that Suetonius is writing in an age, you know, so he's, you know, he's secretary to Hadrian. This is a century on from Tiberius, a time when everyone in the Roman world takes the existence of an autocracy in Rome for granted, but that's not the world that Tiberius is born into and grows up in. And Tiberius, I think, to a degree that Suetonius is unqualified to recognize, is a man who is torn between two different worlds, two different periods, the period of the Republic and the period of the Empire. So it's really important. And this is something clearly that Suetene does recognise that Tiberius was a Claudian, that he's a scion of the greatest of all the patrician dynasties that had flourished under
苏维托尼乌斯写作的时代，你知道的，所以他是哈德良的秘书。这是一个距离提比略一个世纪的时代，罗马世界的每个人都理所当然地认为罗马存在着专制政体，但那并不是提比略出生并成长其中的世界。而提比略，我认为，在苏维托尼乌斯无法认识到的程度上，是一个在两个不同世界、两个不同时期——共和国时期和帝国时期——之间挣扎的男人。所以这真的很重要。这显然是苏维托尼乌斯所认识到的，提比略是一个克劳狄家族的人，他是繁荣于共和国之下的
the Republic. But he is simultaneously being raised as the stepson and then the adopted son being raised as the stepson and then the adopted son of an autocrat, the first great autocrat in Roman history. So there's an enormous tension there. So as a Claudian, he's inherited this assumption that it's his role to serve the Republic, to win glory for himself, for his family, for his city in the traditional manner by organizing grain and conquering barbarians and all that kind of thing. But simultaneously, as Augustus is dependent, he is expected to show gratitude and submission to the very man who has put the Republic in his shadow, who has established basically a monarchy. And I think it's not surprising that this seems to have generated a degree of stress
最伟大贵族王朝之一的传人。但与此同时，他被抚养为专制君主的继子，然后被收养为儿子，被抚养为一个专制君主——罗马历史上第一位伟大专制君主的继子，然后是被收养的儿子。所以那里存在着巨大的紧张关系。因此作为一个克劳狄家族的人，他继承了这样一种假设：他的角色是为共和国服务，以传统的方式通过组织粮食和征服野蛮人等各种事情，为自己、为家族、为城市赢得荣耀。但与此同时，作为奥古斯都的附庸，他被期望对那个让共和国黯然失色、基本上建立起君主制的人表现出感激和顺从。我认为这并不令人意外，这似乎产生了一定程度的压力，
and all the more so because, as we said, in Augustus' household, he is obliged to play second fiddle to people who are much younger and less accomplished than him, but who are being elevated simply because they have the blood of Augustus in their veins, and it's incredibly humiliating for him. But more than that, I think there is a kind of ideological stress because he's torn between the sense of loyalty he feels towards his city and his class, which is, these are Republican dynasties, they're hostile by nature to monarchy. It is the Roman sense that a son should be dutiful towards his father, so he should show respect to Augustus. And I think it's not surprising that Suetonius reports that
而且更不用说，正如我们所说，在奥古斯都的家庭中，他被迫在那些比他年轻得多、成就小得多，但仅仅因为他们血管里流着奥古斯都的血而被提拔的人面前扮演二把手，这对他来说是极其羞辱的。但不仅如此，我认为存在一种意识形态上的压力，因为他在对城市的忠诚感和对阶层的忠诚感之间左右为难，这些是共和派的王朝，它们天生敌视君主制。罗马人的观念是儿子应该对父亲尽孝，所以他应该对奥古斯都表现出尊重。而且我认为并不令人意外，苏维托尼乌斯报道说，
Tiberius really hated his mother, Livia, as well he might have done because it's basically Livia who's put him in this bind. So that idea that you get from Suetonius that Tiberius is a man with two faces, that there's the good Tiberius and the bad Tiberius, that's not then psychologically implausible, is it? If he's a man torn between two very different roles that he feels from birth he has been appointed to play. One of them is the Claudian, the heir to the Republic, and the other is the heir to
提比略真的很讨厌他的母亲莉维亚，他也确实有理由这样做，因为基本上是莉维亚把他逼入了这个绝境。所以你在苏维托尼乌斯那里得到的那个观点：提比略是一个有着两张面孔的人，存在着好提比略和坏提比略，那么这在心理上并非不可信，对吧？如果他是一个在两个截然不同的角色之间挣扎的男人，而他觉得从出生起自己就被指派去扮演这两个角色。其中一个是克劳狄家族的人、共和国的继承人，另一个是奥古斯都的继承人，
Augustus, who's basically going to inherit this autocracy. So it would make sense then that he's somebody who is himself a very complicated, torn, possibly quite unhappy man. I would go so far as to say I am sure that that's what's going on with him. And what makes it worse is that in a sense, under Augustus, the better things get for him, the kind of the worst they become. So in 84, when he, you know, after Garzenousias are both dead and Augustus adopts him as his son, you know, he becomes, he's now the heir to the rule of the world. He's going to succeed Augustus as Caesar. But this is a kind of real nightmare of your principled opponent of monarchy. I mean, it's a real problem, but also there's a kind of deep element
基本上要继承这个专制政体。那么这就说得通了：他本人是一个非常复杂、饱受内心煎熬、可能相当不快乐的人。我要说的是，我确信这就是他身上所发生的事情。而使情况更糟的是，从某种意义上说，在奥古斯都统治下，对他来说事情变得越好，某种程度上它们就变得越糟。所以在公元84年，当他，你知道的，在伽尔泽努西亚斯都去世后，奥古斯都收养他为子，你知道的，他成为了，他现在是世界统治权的继承人。他将作为凯萨继承奥古斯都。但对于一个君主制的有原则的反对者来说，这是一种真正的噩梦。我的意思是，这是一个真正的问题，而且也存在着一种深刻的成分，
of humiliation even in being appointed as heir to the rule of the world because he is no longer a Claudian. That side of him has now been erased. He's a Julian and historians call the, you know, the dynasty of Augustus, the Julio Claudians. There are no Julio Claudians. You're either a Julian or a Claudian. And Tiberius by becoming a Julian has ceased to be a Claudian. And what's even worse is that as Augustus has adopted son, his status is effectively kind of reduced to that of a child. And Suetonius spells out exactly what this means for Tiberius, who by this point, he's a very seasoned general administrator, he's been the head of his own family, and Suetonius writes from that point
即便是被任命为世界统治权的继承人，也有一种羞辱感，因为他不再是一个克劳狄家族的人了。他身上那一部分现在已经被抹去了。他是一个尤利乌斯家族的人，历史学家把奥古斯都的王朝称为尤利乌斯-克劳狄王朝。没有尤利乌斯-克劳狄家族这种东西。你要么是尤利乌斯家族的人，要么是克劳狄家族的人。而提比略通过成为尤利乌斯家族的人，不再是一个克劳狄家族的人了。更糟糕的是，作为奥古斯都收养的儿子，他的地位实际上在某种程度上被降到了孩子的水平。苏维托尼乌斯详细说明了这对提比略意味着什么，此时的提比略，他是一个非常老练的将军兼行政长官，他曾是一家之主，而苏维托尼乌斯写道，从那一刻起，
on, so after his adoption by Augustus, he no longer acted as the head of a family, nor held onto any of the rights that he had forfeited as a result of his adoption, for he neither gave out donatives nor granted slaves their freedom, nor could he receive inheritances or legacies except by adding them to his personal allowance, which technically belonged to his father." So that's Augustus. So to give a modern analogy, which will appeal to our American listeners, it's a little bit like very, very senior American politicians who accept the vice presidency and are therefore reduced to just sort of hanging around in the president's shadow. But it's that but magnified to an extraordinary degree that the Romans take that very seriously, don't
也就是在他被奥古斯都收养之后，他不再作为一家之主行事，也没有保留因被收养而丧失的任何权利，因为他既不发放赏赐，也不给予奴隶自由，他也不能接受遗产或遗赠，除非将它们加入到他的个人津贴中，而这在技术上属于他的父亲。”那是指奥古斯都。所以用一个能吸引我们美国听众的现代类比来说，这有点像那些接受了副总统职位、因此地位降低到只能在总统阴影下闲晃的资深美国政客。但这被放大到了一个非同寻常的程度，罗马人非常严肃地对待这一点，不是吗？
they? The idea of father and son. And if he's been reduced to the level of Augustus' son and heir, he's not nothing, but he's a pale shadow of what he once was. I mean, I suppose I would say the contrast with the vice president is that, what is it? It's worth a bucket of spit. You don't do anything. Tiberius is doing, I mean, he's going off and he's, this is the period when he's going off and stabilizing the frontiers and defeating the Germans and the Pannonians and things like that. So he's doing things. It's just that his legal status is very, very humiliating to a proud man who has always cherished his, you know, his status as a Claudian. Then in AD 14, he becomes emperor in succession
关于父亲和儿子的观念。如果他被降到了奥古斯都的儿子兼继承人的水平，他并非一无所有，但他曾经的地位现在只剩下一个苍白的影子。我的意思是，我想我会说与副总统的对比在于，它算什么？它不值一文。你什么也不做。提比略在做事，我的意思是，他正在走出去，这是他走出去稳定边境并击败日耳曼人和潘诺尼亚人等类似事情的时期。所以他在做事。只是他的法律地位对一个一向珍视自己作为克劳狄家族成员身份的骄傲之人来说是非常非常羞辱的。然后在公元14年，他继奥古斯都之后成为皇帝，形式上，你知道的，没有“皇帝”这个头衔。这仍然是一个进行中的进程。官方来讲，你知道的，他被欢呼为princeps，这意味着第一公民。
to Augustus and formally, you know, there is no title of emperor. It's still a work in progress. Officially, you know, he is hailed as princeps, which means first man. And traditionally, under the Republic, this hadn't been a formal title, not one held as an office, but it was, it was a title that was kind of awarded by the man who was acknowledged by his peers in the Senate, best to have served the Republic. So Pompey had been called Princeps for instance. And I think for Tiberius, he must have been nagged by the sense that had it not been for his succession to Augustus, he might have inherited this title of Princeps, not by virtue
在共和国的传统下，这并不是一个正式的头衔，不是一个作为官职持有的头衔，但它是一个，它是一种由元老院中被同僚认可为最能为共和国服务的人所授予的头衔。例如，庞培就被称为Princeps。我想对于提比略来说，他一定一直被这样一种感觉所困扰：要不是因为他继承了奥古斯都的地位，他本可以继承这个Princeps的头衔，不是靠继承，而是靠欢呼。他本可以通过自己的努力赢得它，而不是仅仅被赋予它。
of succession, but by virtue of succession, but by virtue of acclamation. He might have earned it rather than just been given it. Exactly. And again, you can see that that would make him feel kind of very conflicted, very ambivalent about the status that he now has as princeps, as ruler of the world. And I think that the key to understanding the tragedy of his rule and why he seems such an unhappy figure is that essentially he's trying to square ruling as a monarch with his ancestral respect for the traditions of the Republic. And he demonstrates that this simply can't be done. I suspect that part of what is going on with the narratives of his bad behavior
完全正确。同样，你可以看到这会让他对作为princeps、作为世界统治者现在所拥有的地位感到非常矛盾、非常复杂。我认为理解他统治悲剧的关键以及为什么他看起来如此不快乐的原因在于，本质上他正试图将作为君主统治与他对共和国传统的祖传尊重结合起来。他证明了这根本是做不到的。我怀疑关于他恶劣行为叙事背后的部分原因在于，它反映了这样一个事实：提比略确实开始对他的同胞感到蔑视。从某种程度上说，他在自己角色上感到的挫败感最终发泄到了他自己的家族、元老院和人民身上。所以依次来看看他们，阿格里皮娜、尼禄、德鲁苏斯，也就是奥古斯都的孙女、奥古斯都的曾孙们。这些人不是提比略的血亲。他们是奥古斯都的后代，他们凭此拥有自己的地位。而且我想，这不会促使提比略对他们产生任何极大的喜爱。尽管他们在塞亚努斯未遂政变之前就被逮捕了，但他们在政变后被消除了。而且
is that it's a reflection of the fact that Tiberius does come to feel contempt for his fellow citizens. That in a sense, the frustration he feels at his own role comes to be vented on his own family, on the Senate, on the people. So just to look at them in turn, Agrippina, Nero, Drusus, so that's the granddaughter of Augustus, the great grandsons of Augustus. These are not Tiberius' blood relatives. They are the descendants of Augustus and they have their status by virtue of that. And that, I imagine, would not have encouraged Tiberius to feel any great fondness for them. And although they're arrested before Ser Janus's attempted coup, they are eliminated after it. And it's
可以理解的是，在企图推翻他的政变之后，提比略会感到神经紧张。他会知道，如果人们要试图推翻他，那么奥古斯都凯萨们的血脉就是对他的明显威胁。我怀疑这就是为什么他把他们消除了。接着是元老院，苏维托尼乌斯说，提比略对元老院表现出了极大的尊重。他对待元老院表现得极其好。而且直到他统治的尾声，事情才开始变得有点糟糕。
understandable that Tiberius would have felt jittery in the wake of the attempt to overthrow him. And he would have known that if people are going to try and overthrow him, then it's the bloodline of the Caesars of Augustus, who are the obvious threat to him. And I suspect that that is why he has them eliminated. And then the Senate, Suetonius says, Tiberius has shown the Senate immense respect. He's behaved incredibly well to it. And it's only really kind of towards the end of his rule that things start to get a bit bad. kind of towards the end of his rule that things start to get a bit bad. But two things to say about that. The first is that when you kind of tot up the stats, there are only 52 people who are accused of treason, maestas, the Romans called it, an offence against the
但关于这一点有两点要说。首先，当你统计这些数据时，只有52人被指控犯有叛国罪，罗马人称之为maestas，即一种侵犯皇帝威严的罪行。而这些人有一半被无罪释放。所以基本上是25、26人。按历史上大多数统治者的标准来看，不是暴君，而是任何种类的统治者，这是一个相当微薄的死亡人数。我的意思是，这很难说是一个狂热嗜血的疯子的行为，对吧？是的。我的意思是，这不是斯大林。不。这不是希特勒。
majesty of the emperor. And half of these get off. So it's basically 25, 26 people. By the standards of most rulers in history, not tyrants, but most rulers of any kind, that's a pretty meager death toll. I mean, that's hardly the work of a sort of blood crazed maniac, is it? Yeah. I mean, it's not Stalin. No. It's not Hitler.
我的意思是，斯大林一天处理的人数就要超过这个。而且我认为在苏维托尼乌斯身上，在塔西陀身上表现得没那么明显，但在苏维托尼乌斯身上，有一种感觉，他并没有真正理解正在发生的权力政治。他也许并不理解提比略在卡普里岛上面对的、为了维持他在罗马的地位所面临的挑战。没有人曾经尝试过这样做。而苏维托尼乌斯给出了这个荒谬的故事，称叛国罪审判始于一个人被指控从一尊奥古斯都的雕像上移走了头部，并将其替换为另一个人的头部。而苏维托尼乌斯写道，此后，殴打奴隶，甚至在奥古斯都雕像附近换衣服，
I mean, Stalin would get through more than that in a day. And I think that with Seutonius, less so with Tacitus, but definitely with Suetonius, there's a sense that he doesn't really understand the power politics of what's been going on. He doesn't understand, perhaps, the challenges that Tiberius faced on Capri with maintaining his position in Rome. No one has ever tried to do it. And Suetonius gives this ludicrous story that the treason trials start when a man is denounced for having removed the head of Augustus from a statue and replaced it with the head of someone else. And Suetonius writes that thereafter it became a capital crime to beat a slave or even to change one's
或者把带有他形象的戒指或硬币带进厕所或妓院，都成了死罪，这显然是疯狂的。而塔西陀在他的记述中明确表示事实并非如此，你知道的，事情不是那样发生的。你可以在奥古斯都雕像附近穿上大衣，没有人会砍掉你的头。完全正确。你可以去小便，而你的钱包里装着他的一枚硬币，你不会被捕。至于民众，所以他确实鄙视民众，不是吗？但那是罗马贵族的常态，对吧？这是职责所在。你当然会看不起民众。那是完全自然和正常的。是的。所以
clothes near a statue of Augustus to carry a ring or coin with his image on it into a latrine or a brothel, which is clearly mad. And Tacitus actually in his account explicitly says that this is not the case, you know, it didn't happen like that. You could put your coat on near a statue of Augustus, no one would cut your head off. Exactly. You could go and have a pee with one of his coins in your purse and you're not going to be arrested. And as for the people, so he does despise the people, doesn't he? But that's the norm for a Roman patrician, right? Goes to the territory. Of course you're going to look down on the people. That's completely natural and normal. Yes. So
我们以前在播客中多次谈论过这一点，但本质上共和国的政治是关于氛围而非政策的。它是关于你是保守派、传统主义者，还是你是平民主义者、如果你喜欢的话也可以叫民粹主义者，但他们全都是，你知道的，全都是贵族阶层的成员。提比略不是一个民粹主义者，在这方面他与奥古斯都形成对比。奥古斯都是一个厉害的角色。他没完没了地举办角斗士表演，拍拍大家的后背，让每个人都知道他享受着人民的快乐。他是奈杰尔·法拉奇。
we've talked about this before at many times on the podcast, but essentially politics in the Republic is about vibe rather than policy. It's about whether you are a conservative, a traditionalist or whether you are a popularist, a populist if you like, but they're all kind of, you know, they're all members of the aristocracy. Tiberius is not a popularist and in that he's a contrast to Augustus. Augustus is a great one. He's endlessly putting on gladiator shows and slapping people on the back and letting everyone know that he enjoys the pleasures of the people. He's Nigel Farage.
是的。提比略不是那样的人。他超然于这一切之上。他有点鄙视那种事情。他是罗里·斯图尔特。他是罗里·斯图尔特。我认为他比罗里更严厉、更毫不妥协。但提比略不是，他有点鄙视那些蜂拥去看角斗士表演的人。他对那个不感兴趣。相反，他认为自己的责任是节约国家资源，充实国库。而这反过来，当然意味着他不需要对各行省征收繁重的税收。而这当然有助于解释为什么他在像亚历山大这样地方如此受欢迎。所以我想提比略显然是，他以一种非常残酷的方式消除了他自己收养家族的成员。他确实以叛国罪处死了元老院成员。但我不认为以其他许多罗马皇帝的标准来看，更不用说现代独裁者了，他在任何意义上都是一个暴君。他是一个老派的罗马贵族。他冷酷、严厉、专制。
Yeah. Tiberius is not that. He's above all that. He kind of despises those kinds of things. He's Rory Stewart. He's R Roy Stewart. I think he's a sterner, more implacable figure than Rory. But Tiberius is not, he kind of despises people who flock to gladiator shows. He's not interested in that. And instead he sees it as his duty to conserve the resources of the state, to build up the coffers of the treasury. And this in turn, of course, means that he doesn't need to impose swinging taxes on the provinces. And that of course helps to explain why he's so popular in places like Alexandria. So I think that Tiberius is clearly, he eliminates members of his own
这就是为什么他有这种严厉的公众声誉。他伴随着他那个阶层的传统价值和抱负长大。尽管同时成为一个专制君主家族的一部分曾给他带来巨大的痛苦，但他一直试图尽其所能地履行职责，而且那些能力相当可观。公平地说，汤姆，他的统治长达23年，这是一个充满巨大稳定性、繁荣，最重要的是和平的统治。想想罗马历史上即将到来的所有内战、边境上的混乱，
adoptive family in a very brutal manner. He does have senators put to death on charges of treason. But I don't think that by the standards of many other Roman emperors, let alone kind of modern dictators, he is in any way a tyrant. He is an old school Roman aristocrat. He is flinty, he's stern, he's imperious. So that's what gives him this kind of severe public reputation. He's been raised with the traditional values and aspirations of his class. And although that had caused him great agony to also simultaneously be part of the family of an autocrat, he had sought to do his duty to the best of his abilities and those abilities are considerable. And to be fair, Tom, his reign is 23 years long and it is a reign of great stability, prosperity and above all peace. Think about all the civil wars,
是的，与前后相比，提比略的统治是稳定的一片绿洲。我要说这是史无前例的，因为即使在奥古斯都统治下，奥古斯都的大部分统治时间都花在了征服广袤领土上。潘诺尼亚起义和瓦鲁斯军团屠杀的巨大灾难。在提比略统治下没有这样的事情。我要说的是，历史上从来没有过这样一个在如此广阔的领土范围内免受战争影响的时期。
the chaos on the frontiers that is to come in Roman history. Yeah, Tiberius's reign is a kind of oasis of stability compared with what before and after. I would say it's unprecedented because even under Augustus, Augustus had spent much of his reign conquering vast swathes of territory. The great disasters of the Pannonian revolt and the massacre of Varus' legions. There's nothing like that under Tiberius. And I would say that never before in history had there been such a period of freedom from war across such a vast expanse of territory. And
从这个意义上说，提比略的统治绝对是一项非凡的成就。毫不奇怪，亚历山大像斐洛这样能够认识到这一点的人会说，你知道的，这家伙太棒了。那么，我们如何将这一点与用鱼攻击人、把他们从悬崖上扔下去、干涉儿童、所有这些如此震惊和可怕的事情调和起来呢？所以那个渔夫，这显然是一个民间传说般的故事。那种大喊“哦，谢天谢地，我没有告诉他们关于龙虾或刺梨或其他什么”的人的观念。这是一个在整个历史长河中被全球不断循环的故事。
that in that sense Tiberius' rule absolutely is an extraordinary achievement. And it's not surprising again that people in Alexandria like Philo who can recognise this say, you know, this guy was amazing. How then do we reconcile that with the attacking people with fish, throwing them off the cliffs, interfering with children, all of this stuff that is so shocking and horrible? So The Fisherman, this is clearly a kind of folkloric tale. The idea of someone who cries out, oh, thank goodness I didn't tell them about the lobster or about the prickly pear or whatever. It's a story that gets recycled and recycled
爱德华·尚普林有一本精彩的新书，他曾写过一本关于尼禄的精彩著作，我经常称赞它。这本书刚刚出版，名为《提比略和他的时代：神话、性、奢侈与权力》。我等这本书出版已经好几年了，因为我几年前读过尚普林关于提比略的章节，它们绝对太棒了。在这本书中，他指出渔夫的故事并不是提比略唯一一次出现在民间传说般的故事中，这种方式让他看起来更像一个神话人物，而不是一个现实生活中的历史皇帝。尚普林列出了许多关于提比略的奇怪故事。所以有一种非常诡异的故事，普鲁塔克这位伟大的希腊传记作家报道说，一艘船
across the globe throughout time. And there's a brilliant new book by Edward Champlin, who wrote a wonderful book about Nero that I've often praised. This book just come out, Tiberius and his age, Myth, Sex, Luxury and Power. And I've been waiting for it to come out for years because I read some of Chaplin's chapters on Tiberius years ago and they're absolutely brilliant. And in this book, he points out that the story of the fisherman, it's not the only time that Tiberius features in a kind of folkloric story in a way that makes him seem like a figure of myth rather than a kind of real life historical emperor. And Champlain lists many of the strange stories that are told about Tiberius. So there's kind of very eerie story that Plutarch, the great Greek biographer, reports that a ship
正航行经过希腊的一个岛屿。这里听到这个诡异神秘的声音在大喊：“伟大的神潘死了。”同样，有报道称在西班牙海岸附近的一个山洞里发现了一个海人。这两个奇迹都被报告给了提比略，他成立了小组来调查发生了什么。他在故事中扮演角色，通过寓言来解释他的政策。所以那种评论，“我希望我的总督们剪我的羊毛，而不是剥它们的皮”。提比略是一个好统治者的原型。一次又一次，他成为了几乎可以被称为寓言的故事的主角，这些故事讲述用来阐明永恒真理的故事。同样，这就是这个观点：提比略正被从他自己的时代中剥离出来，几乎充当了
is sailing past an island in Greece. And here's this eerie mysterious voice crying out, the great god Pan is dead. Likewise, there are reports of a merman being discovered in a cave off the coast of Spain. And both of these wonders are reported to Tiberius and he sets up panels to investigate what's going on. He is cast in stories where he explains his policies by means of fables. So that kind of comment, I want my governors to shear my sheep, not kill them. Tiberius is the kind of the archetype of a good ruler. And again and again, he is the star of what might almost be called parables, kind of stories that are told to illustrate timeless truths. And again, this is idea that Tiberius is being extracted from his own age and serving almost as the kind of
一个好皇帝、明君的模范。事实上，尚普林称他为“明君提比略”，并把他描述为古代民间传说中独一无二的人物，一个不断出现在这些故事中但确实存在过的人。但你如何将这一点与他在……上的可怕行为调和起来呢？因为这似乎完全违背了他是一个绝对堕落的怪物的传统。这确实有点违背，但在两种情况下，无论提比略是被塑造为一个怪物还是智者的模范，事实上，通常是一个普洛斯彼罗、一个岛上的魔术师，因为这也是另一个主题。（你知道的，斐洛提到了这一点，没有人比提比略更明智，
the model of a good emperor, a wise king. And in fact, Champlain calls him Tiberius the wise and describes him as a figure unique in ancient folklore, a man who is repeatedly appearing in these kinds of stories, but who had actually existed. But how do you reconcile that then with the terrible behaviour on? Because that seems to run completely counter to the tradition that he's an absolute depraved monster. It kind of does, but in both cases, whether Tiberius has been cast as a monster or as the kind of the model of a sage, in fact, often a kind of Prospero, a magician on an island, because this is another theme. You know, Philo mentions it, there is no one wiser than Tiberius,
但他也能够洞察别人看不到的奥秘。）在所有这些中，（无论是负面的报道还是更积极的报告），提比略都被塑造为一个拥有绝对卓越学识的人，具备洞察超自然维度的能力，这是其他人无法做到的。所以就像你有提比略作为那个弄清潘神是否已死、这个海人是什么或者所有这类事情的人一样，同样，在苏维托尼乌斯对他所有狂欢和堕落的记述中，有一种感觉，提比略正在玩弄神话。所以苏维托尼乌斯写道，提比略在卡普里岛的树林和树丛中建立了维纳斯的圣地，在那里，打扮成潘神的年轻男孩和打扮成宁芙的女孩在洞穴和小洞外索取性服务，当然还有强暴、
but also that he can penetrate to the mysteries that other people can't see. And in all of those, you know, both the negative reports and the kind of the much more positive reports, Tiberius is cast as a man of absolutely exceptional learning with an ability to fathom dimensions of the supernatural in a way that no one else can. So just as you have Tiberius as the guy to work out whether Pan is dead or what this merman is or all this kind of stuff, so likewise in Suetonius' account of all his orgies and depravities, there's a sense that Tiberius is making play with mythology. So Suetonius writes, Tiberius set up shrines to Venus in woods and groves across Capri, where young boys dressed as pan and girls dressed as nymphs would solicit sex outside caves and grottoes. And of course, rapes, fantastical copulations,
奇幻的交合、兽交。这些在希腊神话中关于诸神的故事中比比皆是。而苏维托尼乌斯暗示这就是提比略正在做的事情，他为了自己理智上的刺激以及色情上的刺激而重新上演它们。所以实际上，这些故事是什么，因此，它们几乎，也许这太简单化了，但它们是文学程式的一部分，将提比略确立为这样一个人，我正要说，他不仅仅是人类，但他也许比人类多了一点点。他就是，他是非凡的。他身上有一种非常令人不安的神圣感，因为当然他是神圣家族的一部分，不是吗？皇室家族。
bestiality. These are rife in the tales that are told of the gods in Greek mythology. And Suetonius is implying that this is what Tiberius is doing, that he's restaging them for his own kind of intellectual titillation as well as his erotic titillation. So actually what these stories are, therefore, they're almost, maybe this is too simplistic, but they're part of a literary formula that is establishing Tiberius as somebody who is, I was about to say, he's not exactly more than human, but he is maybe a tiny, a degree more than human. He is just, he is exceptional. He has that very kind of unsettling sense of the divine about it, because of course he's part of the divine family, isn't he? The imperial family.
是的，我完全这样认为。我的意思是，尚普林说，你知道的，这有点像在阅读一位美国总统的生平。然后突然之间，这位美国总统透露猫王其实还活着，或者罗斯well的外星人，你知道的，他把他们放到了公共电视上。它是政治家日常生活的交集，他们解决粮食供应等问题，其中夹杂着关于潘神或色情现场秀之类的各种疯狂的事情。无论是积极的还是消极的，它都将提比略塑造为日常生活与诡异、凡人与神圣、政治事务与文学神话维度之间的接口。我的意思是，这在多大程度上
Yeah, I think absolutely. I mean, so Champlin says that, you know, it's a bit like reading a life of an American president. And then suddenly, this American president is revealing that Elvis had actually lived, or that the aliens at Roswell, you know, he kind of puts them on public television. It's the intersection between, you know, the day-to-day life of a politician who sorts out grain supplies and so on, with all kinds of mad stuff about pan or erotic floor shows or whatever. And whether it's positive or negative, it's casting Tiberius as the interface between the day-to-day and the weird, between the mortal and the divine, between the affairs of politics and kind of dimensions of literature and mythology. I mean, the extent to which this
反映了历史上的提比略，我认为现在已经不可能知道了，但显然提比略的统治和他的性格中存在着某些特质，让人觉得他是一个非凡的人，无论是好是坏。这就是为什么我认为苏维托尼乌斯对他也感到纠结。所以，你知道的，作为一部传记它是失败的，但作为一部神话化的作品，它是不可思议的，而且非常非常有影响力。而提比略的不幸在于，苏维托尼乌斯强调了负面的叙事而不是积极的叙事，因为我认为显然也存在着一个非常积极的传统，在这个传统中，提比略被视为不仅在罗马，而且在整个历史上所有统治者中最明智的一个。
reflects the historical Tiberius I think is now impossible to know, but clearly there were qualities within Tiberius' rule and his character that made people feel he was an exceptional person, whether for bad or for good. And that's why I think Suetonius struggles with him. So, you know, it's a failure as a biography, but as a work of mythologisation, it's incredible and very, very influential. And it's Tiberius's misfortune that Suetonius should have emphasised the negative spin rather than the positive one because I think there is clearly a very positive tradition as well in which Tiberius is viewed as having been the wisest of all rulers, not just in Rome, but across all of history.
好吧，这是一个巨大的声明。所以提比略于37年3月16日去世，享年77岁，继位的是我们之前谈到的那个小男孩，他曾饶恕了尼禄和德鲁苏斯的兄弟，也就是盖乌斯，他更为人所知的绰号是“小靴子”卡利古拉。而卡利古拉，我的意思是如果你认为提比略是一个好角色，天哪，我们在卡利古拉身上会有很多乐子。对于“无休止历史俱乐部”的会员们来说好消息是，汤姆，我们自己的禁卫军，他们可以立即收听那一集关于卡利古拉的节目。如果你想加入“无休止历史俱乐部”，当然可以在therestesshistory.com加入。但如果你不加入，我们将在星期一回来，探讨：他真的是古代历史上最嗜血堕落的
Right, that's a big claim. So Tiberius died on the 16th of March 37 and he was 77 years old and he was succeeded by that little boy that we talked about earlier who he had spared the brother of Nero and Drusus who was Gaius who is better known by the nickname Little Boots, Caligula. And Caligula, I mean if you think Tiberius is a good character, my word, we're going to have some fun with Caligula. And the good news for members of the Restless History Club, Tom, our very own Praetorian Guard is that they can listen to that episode on Caligula right away. If you want to join the Restless History Club, it is of course at therestesshistory.com. But if you don't, we will be back on Monday with, well, was he the most blood crazed depraved
疯子，还是现实更复杂一些？我有一种可怕的感觉，汤姆会说这稍微复杂一点，但我们会在星期一揭晓。时间会证明一切。是的，时间会证明一切。到时候见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来留下评论。
maniac in ancient history or is the reality more complicated? I have a terrible feeling that Tom is going to say it's a little bit more complicated, but we will find out on Monday. Time will tell. Yeah, time will tell. See you then. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
古代历史上的狂人，还是现实更加复杂？我有一种可怕的预感，汤姆会说情况要稍微复杂一些，但我们将在周日揭晓。时间会证明一切。是的，时间会证明一切。到时候见。再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。